- Welcome back to Trump Watch.
And in this latest episode
of a thing I just invented
we are looking at the
investigation of Cy Vance,
the prosecutor in
Manhattan, who is looking
into the Trump Organization
and the Trump finances.
And, according to reports,
Vance is talking to a lot
of different people,
not only Michael Cohen,
who Southern district of
New York federal prosecutors
have talked to seven or eight times now,
but also the ex daughter-in-law
of Allen Weisselberg,
the CFO of the Trump Organization.
And according to The New York Times,
Cy Vance has subpoenaed
the personal bank records
of Weisselberg himself
and are scrutinizing gifts
he received from former President Trump.
Now, of course, this may
never amount to anything
but that has a lot of interviews,
that is a lot of effort being spent
if there's no there, there.
So, it's entirely possible
that we will see members
of the Trump Organization in court.
Just like, I'll see you in
court, if you don't subscribe.